all right and the game just got started
so we're expecting to see a scotch from
xqc do you have any insights on how you
think most critical will reply
um I don't actually know I think Charlie
has been maybe looking at the Sicilian
defense is my guess I don't actually
okay play see five okay
so X EC is gonna get his get his Scotch
opening here I think let's let's watch
let's see alright and if he does get it
then he will be familiar so he's
probably pretty happy to have seen a
five I think
see if I may have put him a bit less in
his comfort zone right I think ii
thought he 45s when a lot of players
like to play and here we go he get the
Scotch opening so X you see is very
comfortable I think this is the main
opening he's been playing a lot okay now
boys critical plays Bishop c5 which is
not a move that I like here if the
system is completely fine in advance
level I'm worried about the plans in the
process here because when you bring out
to Bishop like this it can become very
vulnerable right away so I'm not sure
that I like the like the variational
approach here no please don't
and it's too soon it's too soon Hikaru
we didn't even reach a climax
you
you know when I said it'd be fun to see
a checkmate in four earlier I was I was
joking it was it wasn't real
look we're listening to Moyes critical
right now Daniel Nora ditz key is a
prophet he said immediately that xqc
will likely go with the Scotch open and
he did so I had the counterplay and he
immediately blundered well that's got to
be a world record
thanks for the fat tin gift subs Pikachu
my is throbbing throbbing
what does xqc strat saying right now
okay mm-hmm so he's muted now he's muted
now um that was rough I think he was
explaining that Danya prepared him for
this opening trap right yeah I mean this
is certainly a very basic setup that
makes a lot of sense it's really
unfortunate that X you see blundered
into it but I am guessing she did not
actually look at it ahead of time so if
you if you don't if you aren't familiar
with the exact setup or the sequence of
moves you can get in trouble right away
so it was a very unfortunate unfortunate
game for X you see yeah it seemed like
he was just playing the moves that he
naturally does pretty quickly without
really thinking about what his opponents
plan was and it's easy to do that in an
opening you're confident with right
exactly yeah that's definitely true oh
man
well so xqc will be in the contenders
division but you know on one on one end
that's also pretty helpful because he's
gonna play people more similar to his
rating range right yeah I mean I think
it's it's very it's very difficult
certainly to lose one of your games like
this obviously losing like I think that
was some four moves one two three four
five six six six
yeah but yeah certainly to lose like
this is pretty pretty heartbreaking but
that being said I think in the bracket
consolation X you see will have will
will have more chances he obviously is
his third game that he's still playing
the group stage against Pudge which is
probably going to be pretty pretty
pretty brutal as well but nonetheless I
think when the one good thing is that
everybody will get to play in in a
bracket against players at their level
instead of safe playing on some of the
people who are the we're the stronger
players it's certainly very tough day
for X you see but again there there is
still quite a bit to look forward to
right and we will be talking to the
players pretty soon but if you kind of
had any words as a coach tex QC or
honestly anybody who in a tournament
game they have a really bad fall like
this what would it be um I think the
main thing is just you got you got it
you got to have have some sort of
approach to study the opening phase just
the first couple of moves and you play
just play the first couple of
and you can get to a position out of the
opening where your King gets castle
you're always going to you're always
going to get a game and so I mean it's
it's very difficult but I think it's
important to spend a little bit of time
to studying the opening matter because
everybody everybody is trying to study
as much they can yeah and xqc did have
his opening studied as we mentioned it
does happen so I'm moving forward so
moist moist critical what do you think
his chances are looking like against
Yasuo um I mean I think a lot is gonna
depend on what he gets at the opening
stage of the game I think certainly
Yasuo is a better player there is no
doubt about that but if Moyes critical
can surprise him in the opening phase
get something work where he's a little
bit uncomfortable or kind of in a way
sort of cheese and a little bit then
there could be a big upset the one good
thing is in the match between moist
critical and and yeah so is it the win
it is a winner-take-all since both
players are on three points it is the
critical match the winner of that game
will move on to the champions bracket so
it's great than in both groups and B you
do have the final match of being people
on people having both won one game and
the winner it being a winner-take-all
absolutely and as you actually mentioned
earlier if a game ends really quickly if
the accuracy is extremely high so if
moist critical does end up beating Yasuo
then the tiebreaks is gonna be you know
the average of the accuracy and he's
gonna have a very high accuracy well
actually Alexandra there is no
tiebreaker because they're the only two
people on three points oh okay wait
that's what I'm saying like in Group A
you have the two people on three points
loosely need my I forgot I forgot that
much critical losses first game right so
that's how it's like yeah I'm always
critical loss to hutch so moist critical
in yeah so we're both on three so it is
actually winner-take-all so it's really
exciting that you're gonna have that in
both Group A and Group B we're both the
players on three points play and the
winner goes to champions bracket so it's
gonna be very exciting yeah absolutely
well thanks for correcting there and on
that note chat we will take a quick
break so that we can take a look at what
moist critical is up to and we'll be
back with interviews soon thanks so much
everyone we are joined by Charlie who
streams on moist critical he just beat
xqc in an impressive
smooth tactic can you tell us the secret
to this genius plan oh absolutely yeah
it's not really a secret like this isn't
the Krabby Patty secret formula anything
we knew this was coming
I've been trained by Daniel nah Radetzky
this was inevitable whoever matches with
me in this tournament there's just no
chance I have been blessed by the god of
chess Daniel narrowed its key it's he's
not even a man anymore
he's transcended he's gone well above
human cognitions he is so far above and
he's bestowed a little of that
generosity a little bit intellect onto
me and you saw it on full display here
honestly for xqc zone pride he should
have just resigned in the second he saw
me on the opposite side of this board
wow those are some bold words but you
know what Daniel is such an impressive
chess player an incredible teacher as
well I know that he's actually doing it
full-time now in addition to streaming
so huge shout out to Daniel narrowed its
key um did she predict this move order
or do you know just showed you the
general this move order exactly he
showed you so yeah Daniel no I did
Sookie
he's like the Charles Xavier of Jesse
has all kinds of crazy tactics and
everything he knows what's coming he can
read minds he plugged xqc s like 340
games or whatever put a full amount he's
played he plugged it into a database and
he calculated that he would most likely
start with the Scotch open which xqc
immediately did and with the Scotch open
as you saw here bringing the bishop out
early to develop that and threaten on
that checkmate was a good idea because
of X Q C's lack of experience we were
anticipating a blunder not that quickly
but what we were expecting is he would
maybe go for a fork on c7 and tunnel
vision for a rook and I'd still get the
checkmate it just came even quicker than
even Daniel predicted yeah it did seem
tricky for him because it's an opening
he's played so often so he is probably
playing a little bit quickly here but
you know what this means that now you
you are gonna go head-to-head with Yasuo
to see who's gonna make it into the
championship bracket any thoughts on
that I'm not too brushed up on Yasuo
slore here when it comes to chess all I
know is if he's not trained by Daniel
now I did see I don't know if he stands
a chance unless I come in and I'm just
doubt in my mind or maybe just and just
not in good shape I think I should have
this one Wow i I don't even know how to
reply to that one I will say though that
you have made a ridiculously quick
progress in your chest
the last two weeks or so you've gained
like 600 eloah can you tell us more
about how you're training because I know
Dania has helped with lessons but you've
also been putting in some work there yes
a streaming chess on Twitch is a
disaster because the chat doesn't know
the game but they're gonna spam and
capslock moves that they think are right
and then for me personally since I
always like to interact with my chat I
think that's the fun of streaming I'll
look at those moves and then for a brief
second consider it and be like this move
sucks and explain why so they don't just
start running out of time and losing
games to time but when I play off stream
I obviously don't have that I don't have
like you know my mom over my shoulder
giving me moves and I have to insult or
anything so playing off stream I just
get to focus on like the actual good
moves instead of looking at some garbage
yeah that makes sense and having an
actual tournament to compete in is
obviously very motivating to study I do
you think after pogchamp is over you'll
still continue to play oh absolutely
yeah I think at this point it'd be a
disservice to Daniel if I need to be a
student here I love that that's so cool
and again I think we mentioned this
before but there's a lot of people who
maybe don't know so you have a huge
YouTube channel and you cover a ton of
topics and you did a video on chest
drama I mean what attracted you to that
subject of the into it
just watching hikaru streams so when
twitch just started getting big on
twitch I immediately tuned into
vacarro's streams because I have had a
history of like playing chess enjoying
chess watching and all that so watching
a car room and then he talked about
chess elitism then getting shared on
reddit was things with like a bin
feingold saying you know xqc and
everyone that's not good at chess is
negative talent now is like that's
pretty silly and then it just got
interested in seeing the chess elitism
you know dipping my toes into that
cesspool seeing what that was about and
just wanted to talk about it my channel
is always just like what did I have fun
talking about what do I want to talk
about today and then of course the sex
toys which we've already covered yeah we
did cover your sponsorship there so
again it's cool yeah you know they're
supporting your channel and when you do
stream on Twitch has it been mostly
chests recently or have you been
covering other stuff as well well
recently it's been chess I really wanted
to come out here and win this one in
particular I'd like to win the whole
tournament so that's what I've been
prepping for but this one I'd be lying
if I said wasn't on my mind a lot
I really wanted to just come out here
and when this as quick as possible which
I got lucky enough to do today but
typically when I stream it's just a ton
of different things whether it's
watching for just chatting which you
know everyone does it's not like the
most creative thing in the world but
just chatting stuff playing games
playing games I do a lot like bad steam
games you know games that have less than
one player on them I paid $200 for a one
level game I was the only one in the
world stuff like that well someone
needed to support them you did you did a
good deed there yeah it was actually a
Bitcoin miner so I really did support
them pretty hard enough and he Carter I
know you did some chess with Moyes
critical on your stream before maybe you
can give him some advice and now he's
gonna have you and Daniel Meredith ski
so just like the full trifecta here well
if I guess the first question is do we
act what a what color does he have
against yeah so in the final game I
guess it's the first thing I was
thinking in general um I am gonna pull
that up right now he's gonna have the
white pieces oh wow okay so so yeah I
mean i think i think chart Charlie's
been well I think you've been getting a
lot of help from Daniel specifically on
terms of your white openings I remember
I saw one of those lessons a couple of
days ago so probably I assume Daniel
probably show you something along the
same lines of what were today something
where you try to win the game very
quickly since you're going up that's a
pretty formidable competitor in your
group and obviously you want to win the
whole tournament so certainly just just
keep on doing what you're doing and just
just keep working hard and know you've
been putting a lot of hours um on money
of the days so just keep doing what
you're doing seems to be working right
now yeah absolutely appreciate that it's
been a it's been a long journey getting
here a bit of a rocky return to chess I
was getting absolutely slapped around
especially by one woman named julienne
who absolutely annihilated me that still
stings but it's just about improving
gradually and having help like with you
and Daniel of course it's a real benefit
so appreciate it and before so you're
really looking forward to execute see
now who are you looking forward to
facing next uh well I guess maybe after
I win the tournament maybe looking at to
sit over the board with a grandmaster
and see how I fare there I think it
could be a pretty close game I'm writing
a lot of momentum right now so you know
I'm looking forward to it's really the
next competitors I'm not really too
worried about it should be more easy
like there's some fat dub skis for the
home team III love the confidence it
reminds me a little bit about the human
guinea pig who had this project where he
said he would train chess every day for
a month and then try to beat Magnus
Carlsen I don't know if you caught
coverage of that no I didn't I mean go
well it didn't go well
but he used this guy who is always
trying to master skills very quickly in
a short period of time but I mean even
you've been talking to talk but you've
been improving really quickly so I can
maybe that needs to be your next step
I'm looking forward to it yeah
absolutely and this tournaments been a
lot of fun so really appreciate all you
guys putting this on yeah absolutely and
he car or anything else do you you know
I think just I like your confidence and
good luck going forward certainly I
think when I looked at this group this
story I didn't think you were one of the
players who who would have a realistic
chance of qualifying for the for the
Champions bracket but now you're
definitely it is one game winner take
all in your match forgets yeah so so
good luck and I looking forward to
seeing the next next match thank you man
looking forward to it good bye thanks so
much for being here Charlie thanks for
having me